est ce que la définition du schmilblick
commence par la lettre m
à tout à l'heure on avait donné le choix
entre m et hommes
non on me demande si la définition
commence par la lettre m et cette fois
et bien il faut que je réponde par
l'affirmative que je met 100 francs de
plus dans le schmilblick huy 1300 francs
monsieur nous vous écoutons nous sommes
tous oui alors je propose montures de
lunettes chauffante d'aviation monsieur
voulez-vous me répéter montures de
lunettes chauffante d'aviation montures
de lunettes chauffante
tu as bien parce que je vais ouvrir mon
enveloppe ne partez pas partie
oui alors monsieur attali on me signale
quelque chose de la régie oui que se
passe-t-il que se passe-t-il
rien du tout bien non rires et ou non
pardon nous avions un tout petit
problème nous parce que nous avons
l'impression que ce monsieur était déjà
passée on vous a déjà vu
vous avez aujourd'hui oui oui ah bon
alors là c'est un petit peu ennuyeuse
enfin vous avez aujourd'hui
enfin toute façon vous êtes toulousain
monsieur parfait
très bien alors monsieur vous m'avez
bien dit montures de lunettes chauffante
d'aviation monsieur vous m'écoutez
rewheel bien de toute façon alors
monsieur j'ai moi sur ma définition
monture entre parenthèses articuler ce
qui voulait dire que c'est ce mot était
facultatif montures de lunettes
chauffante d'aviation donc monsieur je
peux vous dire que c'est la définition
du schmilblick vous avez identifié le
schmilblick et vous avez donné la bonne
définition de ce schmilblick
monsieur je vous demandais quel est
votre nom car vous gagner maintenant
le contenu de ce schmilblick qui est de
8000 300 francs 839 1000 anciens francs
catherine et katherine chaque nuit là
que se passe-t-il j'avais bien qu'il ya
un problème
d'autres personnes qui n'étaient pas
passés du tout oui avait découvert le
schmilblic alors comment se fait-il
alors catherine écoutez là je vous
demande comment se fait-il que ce
monsieur est passé deux fois oui je
voudrais les explications je suis en
train alors vous m'entendez catherine
oui oui vous nous expliquer pourquoi ce
monsieur est passé deux fois
je ne sais pas c'est à dire que j'avais
j'avais
de définition oui ma seconde définition
qui était la définition montures de
lunettes chauffante d'aviation oui
monsieur mais puisque vous aviez passé
votre retour vous n'aviez pas repasser
une seconde fois en principe tel ou tel
règlement alors catherine catherine
écouté que personne ne s'énerve je vous
en prie faites un jeu surtout que tout
le monde soit sport car oui pourtant
cette participé à surtout à leur écoute
et oui moi le règlement veut que dans
chaque station
oui les participants posent une question
ils n'ont pas le droit de poser deux
questions voyez-vous absolument pas le
droit de poser deux questions alors dix
ans - alors catherine écoutez moi bien
voilà ce que nous allons faire nous
allons nous référer au règlement
oui nous allons quand même vous allez
quand même prendre le nom et le prénom
de ce monsieur ainsi que son adresse
oui le règlement je pense refusera la
victoire de ce monsieur
oui mais dans le cas où après lecture du
règlement en présence de m jaunâtre
huissier en présence des directeurs de
loire tf il accepte la victoire de
monsieur à ce moment-là ce monsieur sera
notre gagnant bien
et de toute façon je pense que pour
cette fois ci tels le veut le règlement
nous sommes obligés d'annuler la
victoire somme de ce monsieur est de
faire partir un autre schmilblick et de
façon je peux peut-être l'annoncé ce
soir mais je n'en suis pas sûr du tout
écouter mais je vous demande catherine
devient écouter car je suis gentil je
n'attaque je suis pourtant maras et s'il
vous plaît toulouse vous y reveniez
m'écouter de toute façon écouté jacques
sène est soumis
je pense que voilà ce que nous allons
faire après en avoir référé auprès du
directeur de l'irt et f
la somme de 8000 300 francs qui était
l'enjeu de ce schmilblick
oui jacques va être le l'enjeu au départ
du prochain schmilblick de façon à ce
que c'est ça une super nuage en quelques
heures le signaler qu'à toulouse nous
sommes très sportive vous savez une
comprenant toute manière non mais je
suis toute façon content que ce soit un
toulousain qu'éprouver j'ai l'impression
je me le piquer a quand même été
découverts à tous je crois que c'est ça
l'important parfaitement cadenassé qui a
été découvert à toulouse bien maintenant
je pense je pense que nous allons
conclure vous allez sur chaque s'il vous
plaît il à deux personnes dans le studio
qui ont écouté le partager vient alors
que derrière il n'y a aucune raison
écouter catherine nous ne pouvons pas
faire de 2010 un jeu est un jeu un jeu à
son règlement nous devons faire
respecter ce règlement nous ne pouvons
pas faire de l'à peu près et je pense
que là il est de la faute de personne
que ce monsieur est passé deux fois ci
peut être nous qui n'avons pas reconnu
mais je pense que de votre côté
catherine c'est à vous avec les
responsables du schmilblick de
toulousains de vous mettre d'accord mais
je pense que le règlement le règlement
pardon veut qu'il n'y ait qu'une seule
personne qui puisse poser une seule
question d'une personne n'a pas droit de
poser plusieurs questions
donc nous allons ce2 nous allons étudier
ce problème et je pense que le règlement
autorisera par la victoire de ce
monsieur est que les répétons le les
8300 francs qui sont en jeu dans ce
schmilblick et bien nous les remettrons
en jeu pour le prochain schmilblick qui
prendra le départ lundi avec guy lux je
donne rendez vous à tous il faut
féliciter c'est monsieur qui a essayé de
tricher de passer deux fois au revoir
catherine et bien donné rendez-vous à
lundi 18h à nos concurrents de reims au
centre des actualités télévisées rue du
docteur jean qu'elle segal au lieu dit
moulin de la housse et je pense que on
ne nous en voudra pas que ce schmilblick
et un petit peu disons tourné en
en tout poisson pas qu'il n'est pas très
très bien terminé puisque aussi bien
aussi bien 8300 francs seront au départ
du nouveau schmilblick lundi prochain et
je pense que tout est bien qui finit
bien
bonsoir à lundi avec guy lux et les
téléspectateurs rémois